[Music]
ever since the current crisis began in
ukraine the world has shuttered and
dread in anticipation terrified that at
any moment the celebs might get involved
and we all knew that it was bound to
happen
and it only took a few weeks of the
pandemic before charlize theron and her
celebrity friends recorded a video of
themselves singing imagine a rendition
so horrible you'll remember so off-key
and tone-deaf in every sense of the term
that it somehow managed to be even worse
than the original version so what would
the celebs do
about ukraine that was the question what
song would they sing what psa would they
record
these are the questions that plagued us
and now they've been answered and i'm
afraid that it's it's it's far worse
than you could have ever imagined anna
lynn mccord is an actress that i've
never heard of but she's apparently
appeared in many films um her wikipedia
informs me that she is also she was also
a teen choice award nominee in 2009 so
her resume is undoubtedly impressive but
it can do nothing to rescue what i'm
about to play for you miss mccord
has apparently been watching the events
unfold across the ocean and has arrived
at the conclusion that whatever the
particulars of this geopolitical
conflict really it's all about her
she may not be a foreign policy expert
mind you
but she does know based on her
experience
that she is somehow at the center of it
just as she may not be an astronomer by
trade but she still knows that the earth
and the sun and all of the stars revolve
around her and lynne mccord subscribes
to the macordiocentric theory of the
universe you might say and that's what
led her to record and publish this video
your challenge here will be to listen to
it for more than five seconds
without dying of cringe in fact in
penance for all of our sins i'm going to
try to let this play
for 80 seconds
and don't look away
don't cover your ears
don't turn off this off
we're going to endure this together and
and be better for it in our suffering
watch
dear president vladimir putin
i'm so sorry that i was not your mother
if i was your mother you would have been
so loved held in the arms of joyous
light
never would the stories plight the world
unfurled before our eyes a pure demise
of nations sitting peaceful under a
night sky if i was your mother
the world would have been warm
so much laughter and joy and nothing
would harm i can't imagine the stain the
soul-stealing pain that the little boy
you must have seen and believed and the
formulation of thought quickly taught
that you lived in a cruel unjust world
is this why
you now decide no one will get the best
i can't do it anymore i don't know we
didn't get 80 seconds in i just i can't
um
some breaking news for you putin has
heard this poem and is now launching a
full-scale nuclear attack against the
united states because of it
and you can hardly blame him i actually
welcome it well you know this might
shock you to learn but i'm not really a
morning person or an afternoon or
evening person or really a person any
any time of day but i have a hard time
waking up especially and starting the
day without something to jump start my
mornings well i found the solution if
you're looking for something similar you
need to check out cacao bliss cacao
bliss is a cacao based superfood powder
that only has seven milligrams of
caffeine and one gram of sugar it's
composed of 10 different superfoods that
are proven to improve your energy focus
mood and boost your metabolism to drink
all you have to do is mix in the powder
with some hot water or if you like some
nut milk whatever you want now you could
use an old-fashioned spoon but i like to
keep things a little bit classier and i
use one of these bad boys
so oh
um
well how is this supposed to work okay i
guess you hold on
all right what you want to do i wanted
to actually demonstrate because it's
it's actually dangerous to have
really hot boiling water that sprays all
over the place i'm i am right now have
have third degree burns i'm in terrible
pain but
you want to put it in the cup first and
then turn it on anyway
let's take a sip
tastes just like a cow if you'd like to
give cacao bliss a try use the link in
the description below and use my code
matt for 15 off your order again click
the link below and use code matt at
checkout for 15 off your order now there
are times in life
when you encounter something so crazy so
deranged that your mind kind of shuts
down and prevents you from confronting
and comprehending
the insanity in its fullness and a
sentence like
i'm so sorry i was not your mother
has just that effect it's the kind of
thought that only a lunatic could have
in a situation like this much less say
out loud on video
it's therefore not really possible for a
rational person
to understand the thought process that
went into this i mean did she actually
imagine a possible scenario where putin
would be scrolling twitter
stumble across her poem
listen to it and be like swayed by it
did she imagine putin tears welling up
in his eyes calling his generals and
saying never mind the war's off
i choose laughter and joy instead come
let us all clasp hands and
sing songs of love and hope
is that what she thought would happen
perhaps
though it's more likely that she simply
intended to get a bunch of likes and
retweets and pats on the back from an
adoring public which was also a
delusional hope
she probably hadn't thought it through
much more than that also i can't help
but note the fact that anna
from what i can tell based on her
available biography
is not a mother
so she is a childless 35 year old woman
and yet she's quite sure that her
parenting skills if only she had
children would be so flawless that she
could as she says in her poem create a
utopia of quote nations sitting peaceful
under a night sky that's how good of a
mother she would be
i remember when i had similar delusions
about my own parenting skills
maybe not quite that megalomaniacal but
you know close enough
and then i realized that it's hard
enough to get my own kids to go to bed
and sleep peacefully under a night sky
much less entire nations
i still have not mastered that eight
years in
how do you get kids to just go to bed
and sleep peacefully i i haven't done it
one time i have not succeeded yet
entire nations the whole world forget
about it
now the best and most generous possible
interpretation of this poem is that anna
mccord
is sort of sweetly clueless in a naive
feminine maternalistic sort of way and
she thinks that snuggles and hugs can
solve any problem doesn't realize that a
tendency towards conflict and land
disputes and tribalism and warfare are
deeply ingrained in the human psyche
all of the snuggles in the world won't
change that
but if this was just rooted in a sort of
optimistic yet ignorant and
simple-minded misunderstanding of human
nature it would perhaps not be worthy of
the same level of mockery that it's
receiving
because it's well-intentioned you know
just really stupid
unfortunately i think the truth is not
quite so rosy for anna mccord it is as
usual
less a matter of naive innocence than of
extreme suffocating narcissism a
narcissism so immense in its severity
and scope that she not only believed she
could single-handedly cure the world of
violence and war but that it's a good
idea for her to make this claim
while the world is in the midst of
violence and war
and it's for that reasons for the
narcissism that ultimately we must say
um the same thing i would say
tana mccord if i was her mother
you're cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated